[Música]
arrastra león
estáis cómodos tranquilos esto ya no es
una charla ahora vamos a hacer un
pequeño repaso
estáis cómodos tienen bastante espacio
he pasado todo el día no hace falta
pensar mucho más y ya se acaba o voy a
presentar yo soy yo me entran de heredia
y soy el tío con más jeta de toda la
historia de text
yo les cuento que soy cómico y músico y
hasta que estoy aquí cuela
y ahora los los próximos 15 minutos ya
solo es vuestro problema todo lo demás
funciona de mí como cómico se han oído
cosas como todo bien sólo le falta ser
gracioso
como músico se han ido cosas como que
paz cuando para
[Música]
cuando me invitaron vienes a hacer un
resumen así que me voy pero me ponéis un
piano en el escenario
y qué tal va mi carrera como músico pues
mira ahí está el piano este
pero bueno vamos a vamos a ver un poco
las diferentes cosas que nos han contado
le voy hacer un resumen por si alguno no
estaba atento del todo no ha leído todos
los subtítulos lo que fuera
[Aplausos]
iba a hacer la jolla y vas a la charla
en inglés porque es
pero no entra y dos horas
primero nos ha contado maider garcía de
cortázar unas cuantas historias muy
interesantes que luego voy a resumir con
más detalle nos ha contado que vive en
san sebastián como cuando se hablando
con alguien como puedes saber que es de
san sebastián no hace falta que lo
preguntes te lo va a contar en un rato
tengo que deciros que yo a pesar de que
me partí de nacimiento no lo diga nací
en un hospital en san sebastián en el
marco incomparable y nos ha hablado nos
ha hablado de varias cosas y entre otras
nos ha hablado del neodimio el disprosio
y el samario que aunque lo parezca no
son los jubiletas que juegan a las
cartas todos los domingos en el bar de
la esquina
son una parte de nuestro móvil que
conviene que te cuides volveré volver un
poco a este tema luego ha venido a irse
así hasta que te quieras
nos ha contado que los peces toman
antidepresivos
están los tiempos cómo están no pueden
fumar
no pueden beber
no pueden echarse las manos a la cabeza
a mí no me sorprende está mente
me ha recordado a una historia que no sé
si conoceréis que es iván dos peces
jóvenes un día por el mar nadando y se
cruzaron con un pez viejo y el pelo dijo
buenos días qué tal el agua y siguieron
cada uno por su camino y uno de los un
rato después uno de los peces jóvenes le
dijo al otro qué es eso del agua
no somos tan distintos de los peces
volveremos a la conciencia a nuestro
entorno volveré ahora en un momento para
hacer un resumen luego hemos tenido a
celestino martínez que nos ha hablado de
técnicas para los pequeños comercios
para competir con el gigante amazon y
otras amenazas
las técnicas estaban muy bien las
técnicas algunas eran un poco como el
león buscando la presa más fácil era
decir los ejemplos que daba a mí me han
llegado muy me tienen que atacar la
gente la mayor parte está ya perdida la
razón pero hay algunos casos entonces
por ejemplo los runners los runners los
veganos y la gente que vive sola esas
las los runners están siempre escapando
no está totalmente claro de que los
veganos que están siempre saben de que
escapan no está claro que sepan a dónde
y luego la gente que vive sola en la
gente que es capaz demasiado
se han sido un poco el repaso que está
bien y lo hemos visto una charla
que voy a mencionar porque ayuda mucho
con lo que nos han contado y maider y
muy interesante de johan blocks trump
que os voy a resumir por si alguno no ha
leído todos los detalles
nos ha hablado de qué va a pasar las
próximas décadas si seguimos haciendo lo
que estamos haciendo que puede pasar o
no pero lo que va a pasar a primeras
décadas el nivel del mar va a subir dos
metros vale entonces para visualizar
esto yo lo voy a explicar
vitoria está a 525 metros de altitud
sobre el nivel del mar entonces en unas
décadas
vitoria puede pasar a estar a 523 metros
de altitud sobre el nivel del mar
seamos conscientes bilbao
bilbao puede pasar tenemos que pasar de
llamarse el 8
a llamarse el pulso
y donosti puede pasar de llamarse el
marco incomparable a llamarse el charco
incomparable
o sea que seamos un poco conscientes de
este entorno y de lo que y de lo que
significa sobre todo algunos más que
otros luego hemos tenido una magnífica
actuación de un grupo que se llama de
javi
que yo no sé vosotros
pero yo he tenido la sensación de no
haberlos visto nunca antes
ha estado muy bien la actuación y yo les
voy a desear una cosa que espero que no
se siente mal que es que que su música
siempre suene tan fresca como el primer
día
pero muy buena actuación hasta luego ha
habido un pequeño descanso hemos vuelto
a la segunda parte y hemos arrancado con
la charla de asier se vaya charla la
charla de asier sanz nos ha contado
asier que que ve a donald trump en el
desayuno
luego nos ha contado que ve a josé maría
aznar en las montañas
empieza a ver un patrón
ha contado lo ha contado en algún
momento algunas veces que ve gente
desnuda en los auditorios
a ver mucho mejor que ver a donald trump
y josé maría aznar desnudos es el
desayuno
pero bueno muy chula la charla el poder
la imaginación es muy muy importante
hemos pasado a otra charla bueno
teníamos la
ilustración
hemos tenido una charla había vídeo
en inglés de kart isabel y que también
os voy a resumir sobre los peligros de
la privacidad de datos los datos en
manos de las empresas yo me dedico al
software de la comedia y la música como
podéis ver todavía no acabamos pero un
día de estos le digo al software es
realmente peligroso pero tenemos
mecanismos que estoy seguro que todos
utilizáis para proteger nuestros
nuestros datos están las contraseñas
seguras que estoy seguro que nadie usa
la misma contraseña dos veces ni la
punta es en un papel y 16 contraseñas
tipo 1234 luego está otro mecanismo muy
importante que funciona muy bien que son
los botones de las cookies de las webs
en un gran mecanismo de defensa para el
control de datos y luego está el grande
la gran barrera que es el modo incógnito
del navegador algunos de aquí conocéis
el modo incógnito del navegador puede
ser no hace falta que levantéis la mano
podéis seguir de incógnito esto es muy
importante los tiempos han cambiado
cuando yo era un chaval el porno era
para gente valiente
había que ir a una tienda a comprarlo y
en la tienda había gente
el playboy como tienes el playball
si quieres amar y al estar playboy a
esta tras eso entonces ahora con el modo
incógnito todo queda en la intimidad la
privacidad de tu casa el único que lo
sabe eres tú y tu proveedor a internet
nadie más con lo cual cuidado con el
modo incógnito no hemos tenido a manuel
linares manuel es médico nos ha hablado
de maneras de mejorar el sistema en una
serie de grandes enfoques es médico ha
propuesto un método que está basado en
las tres preguntas y ahí es donde me ha
entrado un poco de sudor frío porque yo
no sé a quién le gustan las preguntas de
los médicos
espero que las tres preguntas no sean
cuanto bebés y cuánto fumas
y que te llevas al confinamiento
espero que no sea también el respecto al
sistema mencionar que el sistema somos
todos estamos dentro de nuestra afuera
esto eso existe
el sistema es la suma de todas las
decisiones que tomamos en cada momento
con lo cual cambia el sistema es muy
fácil hay que cambiar las decisiones que
tomas en cada momento y luego hemos
tenido pasar a buesa entonces a mí me
habían pedido que hicieron resumen
cómico de las charlas del día y está muy
bien cuando ves la de ser sal y luego
ves la de sara huesa y ceja
es un trabajo su trabajo pero bueno a mí
me ha recordado una historia antigua
importante aún mantengo maestro zen le
preguntaron
el maestro no funciona muy mal el mundo
hay demasiado dolor en el mundo de
maestro dijo no el mundo funciona
perfectamente hay exactamente la
cantidad de dolor que ponemos en él y es
exactamente así y lo que es ahora nos ha
contado la parte más
importantes nos ha demostrado que
alguien recibiendo la cantidad de dolor
imposible de imaginar uno puede decidir
no aportar más dolor al mundo y gracias
a eso ha cambiado el mundo yo pido un
aplauso muy fuerte
[Aplausos]
luego hemos tenido a william magnífica
actuación yo el visto instagram en
instagram se hace llamar will y los
brazos
me ha acercado a mirar de cerca antes y
tampoco me ha aparecido pero han estado
muy bien la historia del repaso del
blues sólo me ha faltado el blues del
autobús
del señor conductor nazi ha faltado pero
todas las dentro del resto del blues
estaba muy bien hemos tenido a gorka
oribe que nos ha hablado de sus
progresos en detectar tempranamente
enfermedades muy relevantes y muy
importantes un trabajo muy importante y
yo os voy a pedir que imaginemos porque
la energía funciona y la proyección y la
magia funciona imaginemos a gorka oribe
dentro de muy pocos años viniendo aquí a
contarnos cómo sus avances están
ayudando a curar estas enfermedades un
aplauso muy fuerte con estas
hemos tenido un barrido que nos ha
contado es mi tocayo ha dicho que se ha
pasado toda la vida en el monte no nos
podíamos parecer en todo
y nos ha hablado de su proyecto
empresarial de su primer proyecto
empresarial que era una empresa de
viajes de esquí que se llamaban never
too late nunca demasiado tarde
y me imagino los carteles semana santa
en los alpes razón never too late fecha
límite de inscripción ja ja ja ja
su empresa actual se llama el ur
esquivando los chistes fáciles malos
desde muy pronto y le deseamos mucha
mucha suerte en su empresa y por último
hemos tenido a veronica errasti dando el
cierre en una física de alta energía que
nos ha contado una serie de cosas y nos
ha querido cerrar con una clave positiva
nos podía haber hablado de cuánto dentro
de cuantos años se va a apagar el sol y
nos podría haber hablado de que el gato
está vivo pero está muerto a la vez pero
no nos ha contado que un agujero negro
antes de comerse una estrella la
convierte en espaguetis
nos ha contado que no importa todo lo
que comas y lo que engorde es porque ni
a tu abuela ni a la física le importa lo
único si es un gran volumen masivo el
tiempo va más despacio dentro no pasa
nada pero ha aprovechado para contarnos
que a pesar de que las cremas de
envejecimiento no funcionan yo
sospechaba según pasan los años la
sospecha más
por el hecho de que van más despacio el
tiempo
aunque la piel envejezca lo que siempre
sigue siendo joven es el corazón
[Aplausos]
y bueno
ya que ya que estábamos ya que hemos
tenido ocasión he preparado un escrito
un tema para cantar aquí a la vista la
parte cómica la vista de parte de músico
y ya estaban bien los libros
y escribe un tema y lo iba a hacer solo
pero como teníamos por aquí muy buenos
músicos se ha hablado y me va a
acompañar
willy los brazos a tocar este tema para
cerrarla
[Aplausos]
es todo cuestión de estrategia
el tema habla de algo que yo creo que es
muy importante
y el futuro no te rías que esto es un
chiste todavía
el pasado y el futuro estoy funcionando
de cómico por fin el pasado y el futuro
no existen yo lo creo así se puede
cambiar el pasado no todo no se puede
cambiar quien ganó la copa por ejemplo
pero
como decía tom robbins nunca es tarde
para tener una infancia feliz el futuro
se imagina que nos ha hablado así y el
futuro se crea así y es cuestión de
decidir existe la magia no está reñida
con la ciencia aunque se lo comentaba a
veronica antes y no ha mirado con la
cara de que hiciste pero cuando uno
decide ser feliz del mundo conspira y se
resuelve todo para que para que seas
feliz funciona así si deciden ser
infieles también conspiran esos hay que
tener cuidado bueno a la canción se
titula aguas va da en sí este no es el
momento si este no es el momento de
decidir si este no es el sitio de
decidir pues lo que sea que tengamos que
decidir
en otra guerra de ayuda profesional del
escenario
ahora sí ahora sí que estamos
aquí tenemos dos pistas
ah
[Música]
no no
niño es veselá venga luto
[Música]
jose a
fucking ave
ismay taveau
de esta tierra
por añadir
es pagana
lucy barcos en villa golden juan aitor
m
[Música]
baño donde las cosas
hazme tu barco etorkizuna
taira
pues vale vale
[Música]
ser la caixa
en colores
llorar
[Música]
sentando
al chico
[Música]
v
y
[Música]
despertando
metido para sumar
[Música]
ricos
que mata
a ver yo
[Música]
andy
miraría
[Música]
espada
en la que está todo bien
[Música]
sin duda
mucho